Ngày bán být tạm chiến, tổng thủ mi đúng năng trọng đã đặc ra thời hát để phong trọng hủy giáo
hà mắt phản hủy về kế hoạt hoặc hoặc hoặc hòa bình hà mi điểm.
Giò ông để xuất nhằm chấm dứt xung đột tại giải gà ra.
Pháp biểu với báo dưới khi được hỏi về cùng thời gian chiến hà kế hoạt trên,
ông trọng trọng biến, dự đừng sẽ thực hiện kế hoạt trọng ba hoặc bún ngay nữa.
Nó thơ kệnh bảo hoặc hoặc hoặc hoặc hoặc hoặc nếu từ chối kế hoạt.
Chúc đó, kế hoạt hoặc hoặc hoặc bình hà mi điểm được nhà lạnh đạo Mỹ công bố ngay hà mi chiến thật chiến,
sau cuộc gặp với thủ tiên, Israel Benjamin, Neta Giệu tại nhà chẳng.
Thào kế hoạt toàn buồn con tin, báo gồm cả những người đã thiên mạo sẽ được chào trả trong vòng
bởi mẹo ra sau khi Israel chả hai chân 15 tu nhân đang thu an chung thân và một người bởi trông người
PS-Tin bị bắt giữ sau ngoài một bởi thống người năm 2018, báo gồm tất cả phủ nước và trẻ em.
Hoài ra, một con tin Israel được thả sẽ tương đường bởi việc chào trả thi thể mấy lắm người Presting ở giải gà ra.
Phong chào hư dòng ha mắt cho biết đã nhận được để xuất thống của hai nước chung ra hò dại là ai cập và cắt ra và sẽ sớm tiên hành các cuộc thảo lận nối bộ.
Cũng như bởi các phép và Presting khác trước khi được ra phản hồi.